She could go into this other zone
where she was basically untouchable
and it was like an out of body
experience that she then
went into that and then you just knew you
felt it was such an energy I
played against her I
even got it  I get goosebumps because
I played against her, she was
on the way to the Grand Slime massaged,
won the first three Grand Slams of the year and was on the way
to winning the fourth one at the US Open, and
then she had it in the end  She didn't make it, she
lost in the semi-finals but
I played against her in the preparation tournament
and there was such an absurd
energy in the air. I came onto the
court, it was a Toronto and she came
too and at that point I had
already played five or six times against her  played
and she came onto the pitch and
the air was really
electrified, although I've
never experienced anything like that before and she had like a
huge ball of energy around her
that she carried with her onto the pitch,
namely the coin, the coin toss  was
n't over yet and I already knew
that to my trainer